do you still take on jobs that is it
more like if I like the content I'll
consider it and it's not about the money
or do you have to be paid there's
something that you know I want to be
paid here but you know I mean obviously
content is first right I mean not that I
wouldn't do lousy shows
we all have my career I mean I've made
some of the worst movies of all time
what movie is the worst of all time
well I mean I I you know they're almost
Classics uh it I did a movie that is a
classic I think and it's called Uh
Master of Disguise uh oh do you know
that movie yeah it was in a Carvey uh
yeah yeah yeah I do but I haven't seen
it but yes Dana wrote it and uh it's it
was uh he wrote it for his two
nine-year-old boys at the time and right
and it truly is a film for nine-year-old
boys but uh didn't do well it didn't do
well but it was so much fun to work on
isn't that funny how the worst movies
uh you know according to critics and
whatever and how well it does yeah
um are the ones that you have the most
when I did a movie called sorority boys
and people love it it's Colt and I had
the most fun I've ever had on a movie
and I don't regret doing it for one
minute no I think it's funny oh my uncle
thinks it's the funniest movie he's ever
seen he hates everything I've done I I
understand I love Master of Disguise in
its in its terribleness but uh and and
it's it was so much fun you know what
happened with that film uh Dana wrote
the film and uh Adam Sandler produced it
and you know Adam has this group of
people who work with him all the time
and uh his crew and uh he kind of looked
around he says who wants to direct this
movie and uh he nobody raised their hand
and so he said the DP you want to do
this movie and he said no and so finally
the uh the art director said I'll direct
the movie and so he's okay you're the
director and he was and uh the art
director director of the movie yeah the
art director of all of Adams films
directed uh Master of Disguise and uh
and I have to say he directed very much
like any wonderful director you've ever
worked with it was like you know he had
ideas and he would say let's try it
again and you know it was great
that's amazing you know